THEIR NAME ON THE STANLEY CUP.
>> John G.: THERE YOU GO.
VASILY PODKOLZIN.
PODKOLZIN ON THE BACKHAND TO THE
NET.
THE PUCK SLID OFF HIS STICK.
THEN.
>> John S.: NIC PETAN GETS THE
SAVE BUT HUSSO AS LOCKWOOD
AGGRESSIVELY TRIED TO TUCK THAT
ONE IN ON THEY GETS IT PAST PEA.
AND NOW A NICE FEED TO
STICK AND WIDE.
HERE'S A CHANCE.
OHTHE GOAL.
SHOOTS THE PUCK AROUND TOERE.
HE'S ABLE TO COVER AND KEEP
WRIST SHOT LOOKING FOR THE TIP
WAS RICHARDSON.
HE WAS TAKEN DOWN GOING TO THE
RIGHT.
THAT IS CLOSE.
THE REFEREE GIVING HIM A BREAK.
HE'S IN LUKE SCHENN.
GAINS CENTRE AND DUMPS T BY
FAULK.
DAVID PERRON FROM THE NEAR
THROUGH, THROUGH.
>> John S.: IT DIDN'T HITSHOULD.
THAT
FOR VANCOUVER.
HERE'S A LEAD
JUST OVER 9 MINUTES
OF THE PERIOD AFTER THE CANUCKS
OUT SHOT THEM
HERE'S THE BLUES.ALL, THEY'RE R
WING.
ELIAS PETTERSSON CUTS TO THE
MIDDLE.
LOSES THE HANDLE.
HE COMES
VILLE HUSSO, LEFT PAD SAVE, NO
ELEVATION ON THAT ON.
PERRON.
LEDDY.
DAVIVI HIGH THA PUCK
AGAIN.
DIMINUTIVE FORWARD, ONE OF THE
SMALLK FOR
ST. LOUIS.
CHIPS IT
WN FROM THE RIGHT
POINT.NUCKS.
LOOK AROUND.
THROW IT IN BEHIND.
PETTTT BACK.
OFF HIS SKATE.
OUTSIDE THE LINE
>> John G.: VILLE HUSSO IS JUST
ON HIS GAM